I'm doing this show with Knoxville with
with Kimmel and Knoxville now it's
called prank panel and it's basically
shark tank for pranks people come on
they pitch his pranks and me and
Knoxville and Gabrielle Sidibe are like
the three judges American Idol style and
we decide whether or not we want to
produce a person's prank or not
but Knox was pranking me the whole time
he's tasing me he's got like he's got a
different weapon on him every day yeah
and he does and so so I'm like so I
called Jeff Tremaine I go Jeff I don't
know what to do Knoxville every every
day I go to work something's popping out
of a wall or he's like hit me with a
tase or something and Jeff goes well
he's never gonna stop so you got to hit
him back so I have this giant stun gun
next to my bed
so it's like a police grade stun gun so
I was like all right I guess I gotta hit
him I don't want to because I'm going to
hit him he's gonna hit back but what
what can I do so I go to work I have
like a long sleeve thing on pants and
this like police grade it looks like a
baton but it's a stun gun this is your
work sir
so he's talking to the guest this lady
comes on from like wherever Schenectady
she comes on she's like hey I want to
pitch my I want to prank my cousin she's
explaining and while Knox was not
looking I take this this uh a stun gun
out and I hit him right in the heart
with it like in the center of his chest
but he's like the liquid Terminator the
guy's so impervious to pain like that's
like a little pinch to him the guy's
been hit by both 16 concussions brain
hemorrhage that's nothing to him so I
hit him in the heart with his stun gun
and he just starts looking at me while
he's being electrocuted and then he
grabs it out of my hand and then he just
starts attacking me with it and he's
running and he has another one in his
pocket so he takes out another one and
he has mine he gets me on the floor he's
just lighting me up with two guns
and I run for my life I run out of
studio and I quit I quit the show I was
like this guy is like working with the
liquid Terminator I can't prank them
back because he doesn't feel pain right
and and like if and the more I prank him
back the more he's gonna torture me so I
quit that weekend then he begged me back
then I went up then then like I hit him
did he think did he think he were a
[__] because like you know you could oh
no she's like you he's very sensitive so
he's like he's like I'm so sorry you
know what I mean like like I don't want
you to he goes hey we're we got this new
show we get to be punk rock on it on
ABC's Airwaves let's just do our punk
rock thing and it's gonna be okay and
I'm like okay yeah it was like it was
like Ike Turner talking Tina Turner back
into coming on stage you know what I
mean okay baby oh baby I'm never gonna
do that to you again yeah
[Music]
so I get back to work the next day and I
hit him and I rig a little squirt gun
under his desk I hit him in the crotch
with a squirt gun and he gets real like
oh and he's like and I see like he's
getting angry and I'm like oh [__] and I
turned to look at one of the producers
he hits me with a taser in the neck bam
Unbelievable pain like pain that shot up
to my brain and I quit I was like I'm
out I can't I have to quit I would go I
love you I worship you I grew up
watching your stuff I love you to death
but I I can't do that this is too this
is a nightmare so he's like all right
all right no more weapons that work if
you don't bring weapons to work I won't
bring weapons to work so that was hard
that was our truce it's like no more
weapons I mean Gabby and pepper spray on
her at one point oh my God
when I watch this show on ABC will I see
all of that yeah yeah that's what I told
him I go
like I'm coming back we'll have a truce
but uh Aaron I mean like don't put me
through all that pain and then don't air
it you gotta air it but you know what's
going to happen you know what's gonna
happen that's gonna be the best part of
the show and you too and you and YouTube
Maniacs are gonna end up killing each
other I mean when you when you taste
someone in the heart you could have
actually just induced a heart attack in
him I assume it not only did it not
induce a heart attack it made him
stronger he was just like looked at me
while he was getting electrocuted and he
was like oh and then took the weapon out
of my head it was the scariest thing
I've ever seen it was insane it was
insane it was like a James Bond villain
it was like Jaws or something this is
the craziest [__] so so Jimmy Kimmel
produces it and and you guys are the Kim
will have to call me every day and be
like hey I'm really sorry getting hit
with weapons
would be like my therapist every day
is she involved in stunts and things is
that why she is now
super Charming charismatic hilarious
roles of the punches she totally she
totally gets the and she got nervous and
came in with pepper spray and was going
to spray you two guys down yeah because
we're hitting each other with weapons
every day so she's like I gotta defend
myself right
Guantanamo Bay in here I mean it's um so
you're serious I mean you quit the show
oh ask Knoxville I quit I could ask him
well I kept quitting I was like this is
and I felt bad I was like dude I I love
jackass I totally understand your your
stick and I I support it I just can't be
a part of it it's a nightmare I can't be
I can't go into my dressing room
somebody locks the door behind me and
then like snakes and venomous [__]
scorpions come down from the ceiling
every day every day and he's not gonna
do that to Gabby like he's not gonna hit
Gabby with a stun gun he's not gonna hit
me I'm the only one else on camera so
I'm gonna be like in like all nine
jackass guys get it but they get it in
like little increments I was like all
nine jackass guys and one guy so I'm
just getting lit up to them I was like
this is rough
foreign